anyone else like to share
how about you in the back of the glasses
sir my name is Bobby and I am an addict
hey buddy
you know you folks aren't here because
you're gamblers you are here because you
are terrible gamblers
hey Bobby these folks don't need to stop
doing what they're doing they just need
to get better headed who's Lila please
who's that hello
Eureka Billie Jean Bobby Riggs I had a
great idea male chauvinist pig vs. hairy
like feminist your self-governance right
I'm a tennis player that mystery woman
oh my god by the way I shaved my legs
Jean King already a champion of women's
rights as now the most successful female
player oh hi I am NOT saying that women
don't belong on the court who would pick
up the balls otherwise oh my god there's
in a single fan out hated by Bobby Riggs
you know what I'm doing I'm cooking I'm
cooking I won the triple of Wimbledon I
could be fully Jean King Josh you have
enough call Bobby
tell me Tony so Billy Jean way more
don't get me wrong I love women in the
bedroom and in the kitchen we target
Bobby we're not if you spell the words
gonna be when you lose
I'm gonna be the best that way I can
really change you ladies and gentlemen
I'm gonna put the shell back of children
Bobby thinks wow this whole thing's an
actress
there's this sports you name it at the
very top it's a man's world so we want a
little bit of what you've got that's
what you can't see 40 million people are
watching the Battle of you've all been
waiting this battle
you
[Music]
you